how many of you have troubles in the
openings I know I did I have a lot of
troubles in the openings and when I
started to play chess I didn't know what
to do in the opening okay I had a real
problem because all of my pieces let's
say I was playing to white the rook on
a1 the pawns on the second rank all of
them were saying move me move me and how
did I decide which which was yeah I had
a real problem so a lot of my opening
play when I started to play chess was
completely random but I had this image
in my mind okay I imagined that I was
the general of my army and for some
strange reason the pieces in my army
were I I created an image for them so
what I imagined my rook was was a cannon
you know pow shoot a head and I imagined
my knight was like a horse but with a
guy riding on top like a knight from the
medieval ages and I imagine him just
jumping all over the board like a
cavalry man the bishops I thought were
archers you know flying down the
diagonals and my queen I imagined was a
bully she just beat up everybody she
came in contact with she was the
strongest most powerful piece so I
thought that would be a really good idea
to put my cannons that is to say my
rooks in position and my opening moves
were usually
so what was the idea of this move what
do you think young men to get the rook
out my opponent would usually play d5 to
stop me from getting the rook out but I
would move my rook anyway what do you
think my opponent would do of course the
bishop would take the rook and I was
like darn it he got my rook and then I
thought ah
but I was very clever I actually started
the game with two rooks so instead of
recapturing the bishop which I would do
I should do rather I would play this
does this look like a real beginner's
move yeah and this is the way I played
I lost lots of games my opponents
some of them would move the bishop back
and then I would get to bring my cannon
some other clever people would play this
move and you know what I do okay
I still move the rook Jake my other and
I would feel
I'd feel defeated because it was like
man my opponent sees everything he sees
everything he knows what I'm going to do
so as you could see I was a pretty
terrible chess player and I lost all my
games I mean I really really had a
problem I was pretty lousy okay then I
evolved in my thinking I said wait a
minute
what did I think my queen was what was
my queen it's trapped but it's also a
bully
I felt right my strategy of developing
my cannons I'll move one and two and
three
they didn't work very well I figured I
gotta bring out my queen as early and as
often as possible
so I would make a move night any move
that would open a path for my queen
anyway I would it as I got better as a
player I would move either the D pawn or
the C pawn or the e pawn epon became my
favorite and my opponents who would
usually play a move like this and then I
would bring my Queen out and I'm ready
and boy I tell you it was the most fun
when they moved their bishop why why was
that good for me I loved it when a young
man in the back you bet boy I'd love to
take this pawn on g7 and I would then
take the rook I try to take the night
and take this pawn and wipe out as much
of my opponents army as I could and I
was just delighted because I actually
won one or two games I had lost a lot of
games but I won for the first time with
my strategy Tigran
yeah let's say he goes here I take the
risk
yeah and I'm tacking the night well he
could protect the night or he could
protect the night maybe with his queen
but either way then I would wipe out
that pawn and I feel real good and I
like okay so my queen strategy was wrong
but on some occasions I won a game or
two and I was convinced I was right
later as I played stronger opponents I
realized that my Queen strategy just
didn't work against somebody who didn't
allow me to capture their material like
the pawn on g7 so now I had to change my
thinking how do I become better in the
openings when my can and strategy failed
when my bully strategy failed and I
needed an understanding okay
and this is where I really started to
get good I had a different attitude
about the opening because now somebody
told me about the battlefield the
chessboard battlefield if you put your
hand on the chess board
it feels flat right so all the squares
are the same but a good general knows
that's not true that they're actually
high points on the battlefield and these
four squares these squares
efore D 5 D 5 and d4 these four squares
are the highest on the battlefield it's
like they're the big hill these four
squares are the most important squares
in the squares that immediately surround
them are on a second hill so it's like
everything is flat every every other
square is flat
then these squares from F 3 to F 4 F 5
to f6 to ecigs to d6 to c6 to c5 to
Seaforth to c3 and back across d3 III f3
their high ground and then these squares
are the highest ground I go oh that's
cool now I'm a good general now I
understand the battlefield and it's
important to control the high ground now
I began to understand something else
about the opening all of our opening
moves should be aimed at controlling the
centre we should always aim to control
the centre so now I had a new concept a
new idea that I had to control the
centre I had to control the centre so
now I began to understand what might my
original opening move this move h4 is
this a good move in terms of controlling
to centre
in fact it's a lousy move because it's a
move on the flank and it does nothing to
control the centre it was like oh my
gosh I was playing terribly so my
opening move became this was my
favourite opening move what we called
the King pawn or e2 e4 why was this
opening move so good because it
controlled d5 it attacked f5 and it
occupied the sweet center the e4 square
now let us say that my let's choose a
move for our opponent that also controls
the center what's a good move for one
young man yes which one II thought
that's a fine move this is a classical
defense so when we talk about White's
move we talk about white opening when we
talk about
Black's move we talk about blacks
defense so white opened with this King
pawn black defended with a classical
King pawn defense so what do we think
this night starts shouting at me this
Knight says move me move me this other
Knight says no no no don't move him move
me I want to get into the game so what
this move be a good move you all are
saying no I thought that that would be a
good move but why can somebody tell me
why it's not a good move young man in
the orange yes you exactly so now that
is perfectly explains what I was
thinking this Knight is moving away from
the center so it wasn't a very good move
tigran's move d2 d3 is very very
attractive to to me at the time that i
was starting to understand how to
control the center the reason why d2 d3
was very attractive is because this
bishop on c1 was yeah exactly the bishop
on c1 it's riding the bench man it's not
in the game it's saying get me into the
game so as I was ready to play the move
to d2 d3 this other Bishop it started
shouting it said don't move the D pawn
why did this bishop shout don't move the
D pawn correct because now it's way has
been blocked by the palm so what I
decided to do was bring my bishop out to
sea for so I would develop my bishop and
in my mind this was a really really good
move because it controlled the sweet
center squared d5 okay now let's say my
opponent is quite good themselves
and they played the move night on g8 to
f6 playing in the center attacking my
pawn on e4
tigran how did I respond Knight to f3
that would be a counter-attack against
the pawn on e5 I wasn't very
sophisticated enough to play such an
outstanding move as night at 3 I
actually played your move
I play d2 d3 the reason I played d2 d3
is because I was actually getting good
and I could see that my pawn was being
attacked by this night so I defended the
pawn that was in the sweet center
well now it's blacks turn the other
reason I was now happy to play d3 cuz I
would open up my bishop now let's say my
opponent played d5 ooh my opponent's
pretty good too
he's exactly that move controls both the
d5 square the sweet center square and
the e4 square and it attacks my bishop
okay exactly
oh no is right so I see I started
thinking what should I do
I was afraid okay I was afraid that if I
move my bishop backwards my opponent
would take upon and I could see that
that would result in a lost pawn
position for me I like my pawns I didn't
want to lose my pawns I wanted to keep
them
so I played differently what did I play
in this position what did I do
I in then yes I did I took the pawn e4
captures d5
yes but at least I've captured upon so
for the moment I'm upon ahead now my
opponent did a good move
he took the pawn with the night okay now
that is a strong move now it's even
Stephens on the material
I've won upon my punter right
don't take the knight now I was thinking
in this position sorry can I make him in
check I don't know I was thinking that
in this position that I respected what
my opponent had done because in my mind
I understood that he had opened up the
way for both of his bishops and that's
pretty good my opponent is ready to
develop his bishops quickly but but and
this is important I still hadn't
overcome my belief that the Queen was a
bully and I still I still I like that
idea of jumping out with my queen with a
big surprise and so what move do you
think I made man I did I played Queen to
f3 so what was going on in my mind's eye
for the first time in my chest career I
was coordinating my pieces my queen
it is a bad move my queen attacks this
pond but more importantly my bishop and
my queen cooperate to attack the knight
on d5 I loved it when my opponent moved
his Knight away because now I didn't
worry about Knight take c2 checking my
king and winning the rook because I have
I have a checkmate I would play Queen
takes f7 checkmate because the bishop so
this was a kind of a coordination of my
pieces that up to this moment in my
career I didn't understand that the
pieces can work together as a team now
my really good opponents they did not
move their Knight they protected the
night with their Bishop yes at the
moment the Queen on d8 protects the
knight once that I attack the knight on
d5 twice so now the knight is protected
now it's all about the Knights so now I
still understood the idea that I needed
to play in the center I needed to play
central control and what move could I
make that made sense to attacking the
center what move can I make
every space correct the Queen a really
good move for white would be able to
develop the knight to its most natural
square F 3 which would attack the pawn
on e5 now I understood that the Queen
was in the way on f3 and I should move
my queen
so I played the move Queen efore getting
out of the way for the night but also
attacking the pawn on e5 what do you
think my opponents did
okay pond c6 is not a bad move as it
defends the night one more time but it
doesn't address the very specific threat
that I had in mind which is capturing
the pond can black defend the pawn on e5
while developing his pieces young man
and ah yes that's a good move he could
move his queen to g6 could he move his
Bishop to d6 yes how many think you
could move the bishop to d6 well first
of all congratulations it's legal it's
legal that is according to rules you can
move your Bishop to d6 you haven't
suggested in an illegal move now I
forgot that I was playing a very
sophisticated opponent and when my
opponent played Bishop d6 my eyes lit up
because I was greedy and I thought I saw
an opportunity what opportunity do you
think I saw young man yes yes I was so
happy the white bishop on c4 captures
the knight and I look forward to a
winning game Bishop takes we'll find out
if that's true
Bishop takes Queen takes now in this
exact position
I had a big smile on my face why because
I did something that I should not do it
was a trap that I fell for I always
looked and counted
the pieces that came off the board so at
this exact moment I was thrilled that I
was a piece ahead I have an extra night
Bishop and night Bishop and Bishop and
night that I have an extra night and I
thought I could win instead of
concentrating on what comes off the
board your concentration should always
be what's on the board now what move did
black make that made me want to cry what
did I do
what did my Bishop to b4 check oh I
didn't see that either oh oh oh oh this
was brutal I was thinking about the
piece I was ahead by looking off the
board and didn't realize I didn't even
know what this kind of maneuver was
called it's to call the discovered check
the bishop moves with a check to my king
but he also his Queen makes a discovered
attack against my queen
that did hurt yes young minute yes
indeed I could move my knight to c3 the
problem is that when he takes my queen
my knight is in an absolute pin there
are two types of pins do you know what
they're called there's two types of pins
young man
correct correct
so an absolute pin is that this night is
absolutely pinned it cannot move now if
there was a rook instead of the king the
knight could mean that at the cost of
the rook so there's just a normal pin or
a pin and there's an absolute pin in
this case I'm in an absolute pin and I
lose my queen that did hurt so in my
effort I'm gonna lose my queen I
realized Earth
I wanted to take as many pieces as my
opponent as I could for my queen tigran
what did I play that's what I play I
blocked the check to my King by
attacking my opponent's Bishop
unfortunately for me my opponent was
really good he captured my queen correct
so what did I do
I took the bishop and I was super super
happy well not really happy I had a
bishop at night he had my queen now what
did my opponent do give it some thought
what did my opponent do young man
remember that moment ago and I was
showing that my Queen was a bully and I
would take this part and take the rook
and take the knight guess what just
happened to me he did the same thing to
me that I wanted to do to him he took my
pawn and there was no way I could defend
my rook so he would wipe me out and now
I realized I think this Knight should be
over here sorry I apologize I realized
that my my strategy of moving out my
queen early is not that good
correct bringing out the Queen later in
the game is much better so now I still
would get these positions this position
I'd open with my king pawn my opponent
hey this is kind of cool I think I just
discovered upon my opponent made the
King pawn defense I bring out my bishop
later later I make a fantastic discovery
do you know what I discovered what do
you think I discovered what do you think
I discovered that but I also discovered
that every move every move that I make
in the opening that it's that plays
towards the center has a name and that a
lot of books have been written about
chess openings and I discovered that
this opening move Bishop c4 has a name
do you know what the name of the opening
is are you ready for this it's a real
good one it's called the T grid
nope it's called the bishops opening I
wonder why
there you go chess is a logical game now
we're gonna continue from that position
that we had a moment ago I defended the
pawn with life on my opponent place here
I took my opponent took yes I that was
the next stage in my development I
realized that my move
Queen f3 was a mistake because it
stepped yeah it stepped in the way of
the night but I was stubborn all great
chess champions have a stubborn streak
in them what I mean by that is they
believe in their own ideas you should
too what that's correct I could move the
knight to e2 thereafter but I thought
that my knight deserves the f3 square I
still believed at that time that my
queen was a bully and instead of moving
my Queen to f3 I moved it to h5 correct
to bully the King on f7 and I really
really really loved it when my opponents
played here why young man in the blue
blue
check I would love to take the pawn on
e5 check first of all like my good
opponents wouldn't but some of them
would fall for it and if they move their
Bishop I take the rook if they move
their queen while I'd have to trade
Queens but I wanna pawn my good
opponents they played Knight to c6
defending the pawn on e5 now remember
what we had with a moment ago we had a
problem with our night that night on g1
wasn't effective but now tada
well now ya know man this is really cool
it's about the pawn and I want to play
the move Knight takes e5 I'm really
really happy okay now you see that I'm
starting to understand that I should
coordinate with my pieces I'm starting
to rim a moment ago my bishop and Queen
were coordinating now my night and Pont
and my knight and queen are coordinating
and I'm really really dreaming that he
will attack my queen why would that be a
terrible move young man in the blue yes
that is exactly right
our famous I want the same checkmate I
fell for 20 times I get a couple in
myself so my opponent would understand
that this pawn is attacked by the knight
and by the Queen and if they defended
the pawn with this move this would be a
bad move why would that be a bad move
correct I could take the night remember
last time there was a discovered check
against my queen would a Discoverer
check not still be good for my opponent
yeah it's checked in my king and he's
sorry
why what could I do against discover
check young man c3 correct and then if
he'd and they paid to if he took my
bishop what could I do I take his bishop
and I have he has Bishop Knight
I have Knight Bishop Knight so I
actually win material so the move Bishop
d6 correct so the move Bishop d6 is
actually wrong and my opponents instead
a plane instead of defending this pawn
they attacked my queen
now my queen doesn't have so many
squares to move to my queen if it moves
here why is this square bad young man in
the back remember when I used to lose my
rook on h3 say exactly so my queen can't
move here my queen can my Korean can't
move h6 because of a bishop I'd have to
move to g5 or h4 I would choose the move
g5 and then they would trade Queens I
would take with the bishop and I haven't
won anything
Tiran yeah okay
so now my opponent could simply defend
the night or maybe now he could go on
the offensive and I had lost the
initiative my opponent has the ability
to make threats against my position so I
finally realized a very important lesson
which you guys seem to know already
which is don't move the Queen out early
but I kept trying I kept trying I kept
trying until finally I got it don't move
the Queen out early so it took me a long
while but I started to get better I
started to get better and instead of
moving my Queen out I've moved my knight
okay yes that's what I thought now I'm
attacking the pawn on e5 what do you
think my strong opponents would do what
do you think my strong opponents would
do they would defend the pawn on e5 by
moving their night out
seems fair right now I did something
that was very very important in fact I
was yeah
in fact I was such a bad player probably
my first 50 games I never castled
because I never got I was moving my
rooks so I never had the opportunity to
decassle later I began to appreciate
that castles is a really good move
because it gets my king out of danger
yeah and puts it into safety now let's
say my opponents would play what do you
think's a good move for black what's a
good move for black Tigre
what's a good move for black Bishop its
Bishop f8 to d6 don't forget don't
forget the night at the moment requires
the protection of the Queen and the
bishop would be in the way young man
Bishop e6 that would be an excellent
move and I think a lot of my opponents
played that kind of move now remember
what we were talking about this idea of
controlling the center to bring all of
our pieces into the center how could I
attack this pawn on e5 what's a good
attacking move young man rook e1 very
good
now notice now something else something
conceptual has happened that's really
really cool before I was always using my
queen I was trying to make a an attack
with my queen in the knight a queen and
a bishop now my rook and Knight are
attacking this pawn on e5 that it uh
yeah pretty cool huh now let's assume
that my opponent wants to defend this
pawn on f5 and he advances his pawn to
f6 do you think this advances good or
not
who thinks this is a good advance not
too many how many of you think it's a
bad move okay so for you guys who have
your hands up I'm about to ask you a
question the question I'm going to ask
is why you think it's a bad move so keep
your hands up for those who think they
have the answer okay why is f7 f6 in
your mind a bad move it would have been
better to defend upon by developing a
bishop by moving the pawn to f6 one of
the things that is wrong with this move
is the bishop on e6 a moment ago sorry a
moment ago the pawn on f7 defended the
bishop on e6 now after the move f7 f6
the bishop is no longer defended okay
fair enough
that how could white exploit the fact
that the bishop is no longer defended
you know what I play I thought this was
a really cool move remember earlier I
moved the pawn one square well now that
I thought my King was in safety I was
more I moved it again ooh
how many thought that was a good move
yeah that softened up the pawn on e5
because what would happen if he took my
pawn
young man what would happen I could take
with a knight that's a good move young
man I could take the knight on d5 that's
kind of a reasonable move but I have a
really stronger move yes remember that
move f6 that left the bishop unprotected
ooh right so this what we just did
together right now is how I think
the opening I would literally talk to
myself and I go hmm mentally that is I
would say didn't he leave his bishop
hanging and I began to understand that
in the opening all my attention should
be focused on the center okay on the
center so every move that I made in the
opening then had a very very clear
guiding principle my guiding principle
was to control the center with my pawns
and pieces later as I became really good
I began to understand I should castle
I should castle so if you were playing
you go for example to the club and you
sit down at the club and you don't know
your opponent your opponent's a stranger
you never played them before and he
played the move a two a four on the
first move you would think to yourself
oh oh my opponent doesn't know what he's
doing and you would be right and that
move is the move of inexperience when
you play chess a lot you begin to
recognize who are the good players and
who need to improve if your opponent
played the move d2d four of the starting
move oh now you might think this a
second I'm playing a pretty good player
why is the move d2d for a good move
young man it's controlling the center
you put your pawn on the sweet center
square now let's say just for argument's
sake that your opponent attacked your
pawn with the move c7 c5
what would you do you would take it okay
and let's see the consequences of that
move d4 capture c5 let me tell you that
capturing the pawn would be the first
thing I would look at I always look at
captures I love to capture my phone it's
materials yeah so now we assume that now
that we're a pawn up we're doing great
right that we're going to assume that
black is gonna want to recapture that
pawn so what do you think is a good move
to recapture the pawn young men Czech
Queen to a5 check that does recapture
the pawns
it attacks our King and it prepares to
take the pawn but here's a question I
might ask of you does the Queen coming
out early violate our principle of not
bringing the Queen out early with the
move Queen a5 check respect respect to
our opponent he is going to win back the
pawn on c5 but that principle we had of
not bringing out the Queen too soon has
been violated right
our opponents bringing his bully out too
soon so we think that this move is not
so good for black so what should we at
how should we answer this move young men
yeah what do you think first we have to
we have to protect our King from check
young men
Bishop d2 that's a worthy move but now
this is where we start planning ahead in
our minds eye we understand that on his
next move
the Queen is going to capture this pawn
and then maybe we want to play Bishop to
e3 attacking the Queen developing with
the tempo how many of you are familiar
with the concept developing with a tempo
this is a very very important concept in
the opening first of all I'm going to
show you the best move white develops a
knight Knight to c3 black recaptures the
pawn Queen takes e5 white continues to
develop into the center with the movie
for let's say black develops a knight
now here is that concept it's a very
very important concept please understand
how an vital it is for you to understand
you now play the move Bishop on c1 to e3
developing a piece from its original
square and you're attacking the bully
the Queen on c5 the Queen on c5 better
move if it doesn't move
you're gonna capture the Queen so now
you've developed with the tempo our
opponent has to move his queen now the
black queen could move to b4 may be
attacking the pawn on a - the black
queen could move to a5 the black queen
could maybe move along the fifth-ranked
the black queen could retreat to d6 let
me ask you a question to see if you
understand the concept let's assume
black plays the move Queen e5 which is a
really strong move right because it
attacks our pawn on e4 this is a great
move correct how many think I'm tricking
you yeah I'm tricking you why is the
move Queen II five
young man correct in the first place the
Queen on e5 really doesn't it it does
attack our pawn on e4 but if the Queen
took it our knight would take the Queen
so it's a fake threat it's not a real
threat that black has is not taking and
with the Queen on e5 it's vulnerable to
what which is called developing we're
developing with the temple we would
eagerly we'd be really really happy
about this get ourselves all excited we
now bring in a night off the back rank
to f3 we attack the Queen we develop
with a tempo what this is leading to is
it's attacking the Queen and the Queen
drops back to c7 okay
Queen drops back to c7 now White has one
two three four pieces developed Black
has one two so we say that White has a
lead in development okay of four to two
what's a good move here for white what
move would you like to make young man
excellent move Bishop to c4 you bring a
piece off the back rank you prepared to
castle your king the bishop on c4
protects or attacks rather the square d5
as well as a six as well as f7 that is
an excellent move I like it maybe maybe
it's even the best move is there another
move that any of you find attractive
there are another move that think about
developing with a tempo for a moment
young men Queen d5 okay in this case
it's kind of a role reversal
we brought our bully out but could black
now develop with the tempo against our
queen could he bring his knight to f6 or
maybe his pawn to e6 we'd have to move
our queen again okay but I began to
understand that the queen is a bully but
in the opening if you could attack the
Queen you could push the Queen around so
I want to attack blacks Queen yes Knight
to d5 now this move I really like Bishop
c4 is excellent and maybe the best move
but I found this move to be very
attractive because I realized that the
Queen would have to move again
maybe back to its for the original spot
but if it moved back to its original
spot it means from the very start
bringing the Queen out actually turn out
to be a bad idea because it wait it
wasted time so this was how my thinking
in the opening evolve and I went from
being a real beginning player to being a
sophisticated player learning to bring
out my pieces and pawns to control the
center learning to castle early put my
king and safety and keep a lookout for
when my opponent brought his bully out
so I could attack